good morning ladies and gentlemen on
behalf of the Royal Swedish Academy of
Sciences I would like to welcome you to
this year's lectures by the Nobel
laureates in physics and chemistry and
the laureates of the Rick's banks Prize
in Economic Sciences to the memory of
Alfred Nobel this is textbook material
we've all heard such a statement
significantly it's what you can state in
your manuscript without having to find
the reference it's knowledge you can
master if I woke you up in the middle of
the night but before things become
textbook material you actually have to
know who was responsible you could maybe
say as shown by haroche or Weinland as
evidence by Lefkowitz or kobilka as
demonstrated by Shapley or roth but what
happens when you get a Nobel Prize is
that you simply become textbook material
because what you did is no longer a
hypothesis no longer a new idea but it's
become part of the realm of our combined
knowledge the basis upon which new ideas
are created and the things that everyone
knows it's what we've been told in
school read in university textbooks been
told by professors and we easily forget
that these facts are not trivial and are
far from self-evident
they've arisen from hard work much
thought insight much analysis and much
persistence
and made by individuals who were given
the gift to formulate new concepts and
ideas that were of the kind that have
changed our general picture of the world
and yes the people are duly honoured
they come to Stockholm and for a few
years at least books will still write
that this knowledge this understanding
emanates from the work of specified
people but the day will come when these
facts will become just general wisdom
but we're not there yet because during
these days in Stockholm we want to make
it clear that new insights into the
essence of the material world come from
real people doing real experiments in
real laboratories some that work some
that fail and importantly some that give
results not at all expected
thus ladies and gentlemen we will today
have the pleasure of following the
development of new concepts and ideas by
those who have actually made them today
and in the coming days we honor those
who created and persistently followed up
ideas and visions that were new and that
have now acquired the status of being
worthy of a Nobel Prize and thus will
become textbook material I would now
like to ask professor Brock byung-eun
son to present this year's Nobel Prize
in Physics and the Nobel laureates in
physics for us thank you
good Anuradha the Louis is here search
Josh and David Wineland work in a very
active research field called quantum
optics in this field of physics
fundamental interactions between light
and matter are studied in fact
interaction between light and particles
with the light particle photons and
matter is the reason why you can see me
standing here the Nobel Committee has
especially singled out groundbreaking
inventions made by the laureates that
has led to the possibility to measure
and control individual quantum systems
dreams or such studies have been around
since the dawn of quantum physics but
has become a reality first now their
methods have in fact many things in
common
David Wunderland traps electrically
charged atoms called ions controlling
and measuring them in photons which are
the particles a light sensor washed on
the other hand take the opposite
approach he controls and measures thread
photons by sending specially prepared
atoms to the trap where the atom acts as
spice giving information about the
photons without destroying them the work
has opened up a new era of experimental
possibilities in the experiments they
study fundamental questions in quantum
physics like the transition towards the
classical world called decoherence one
of the case in his realization of the
most precise clocks ever seen and this
year's prize has actually also paid the
way through his future quantum computers
computers with performances that would
be dreamed for computer science and the
two laws has also another thing in
common they like the same cat no no
Sawyer said it's wrong they liked the
same cat no no I'm wrong again they like
the same cat
well maybe the like and like the same
cat at the same time I cannot find out
so we have to
about that so we start this lecture
speed with Sara Raasch he was born in
1944 in Casablanca in Morocco he got his
PhD 1971 from the University of pyramid
equally Perry Falls he is professor at
collector Falls and Ecole Normale
Superieure Padilla in France
and now I give the word to
quantum physics has revealed that matter
and light can have a particle and a wave
like character at once atoms which are
usually described as discrete entities
can also behave as a matter waves and
light which is usually described as an
electromagnetic wave is made of single
particle discrete particles of photons
this duality has led to a strange world
in which atoms and light fields can
exist in state superposition so to speak
suspended between different classical
realities the phases of quantum physics
which have discovered these laws by
observing properties of matter and
radiation which could not be explained
by classical physics we are not able at
the time they were founding the theory
to observe directly this strange
behavior on particles of light or matter
so they imagined thought experiments for
instance Bohr and Einstein in their
discussions imagined that they would be
able to trap single particles for
instance single photons you see here the
famous photon box that bodies drawed
when discussing with Einstein in which a
photon would be stored and then released
on demand so this shutter and you see
that the explain was not real but Bob
draw it with exquisite precision and you
see the address and clock here which
plays an important role in the
experiment I will come back to this
later but at the time they were thinking
about these experiments Einstein ball
and Schroedinger did not believe that
such experiments would one day become
possible of course they knew and
shreddin be anew in the 1950s that
single particles could
detected but the detection occurred by
destroying the particles you see here an
example of traces in a bubble chamber
also in accelerators when particle
collide you see the day breeze of the
collision after the particle has been
destroyed so in fact it was post-mortem
physics the objects were destroyed while
being observed and Schrodinger put it in
a very nice way when he said it is fair
to state that we are not experimenting
with single particles anymore that we
can raise equals area I don't I'm not
sure I pronounce correctly in the zoo
we are scrutinizing records of events
long after they have happened so
particles exist but it's difficult to
have them in a zoo but things have
changed since then and now we are
performing these thought experiments
have become real and we can control a
zoo of particle make 10 them and observe
them and this has become possible due to
the development of new quantum
technology first of all tunable lasers
which allow us to explore with very high
precision the structure of atoms and
also to many plate atoms you also need
fast computers to analyze the data and
to take in real times that are provided
by the experiments and in some cases you
need also superconducting technology to
have mirrors which will hold the photons
a particle of light long enough and I
think it is interesting to note that
these technological inventions are all
born from quantum physics so it's a very
nice circle which is closing here from
quantum theory
you get quantum technology which enables
us now to demonstrate directly the
strangeness of the quantum world so many
experimentalist in the world are now
working in this field called quantum
optics or quantum information and they
are able to tame this particle in real
to the real world this year Swedish
Academy of Sciences as we just heard has
decided to think to just two
put this field forward by building
surprise the Nobel Prize in Physics to
David Wineland myself but I am sure he
agrees with me that we are just here as
a representing Sui are representing a
very wide field of physicists and I am
very glad to see that many of them
working in labs in the world are here
today it has also been pointed out that
the experiments that we are doing in
Paris and the one which are done in Buda
are very similar there are two sides of
the same coin
while David Buda is manipulating single
atoms with photons in Paris manipulate
single photons with atoms and we both do
it in vivo as opposed to the post mortem
physics that we are talking about before
now just to show you the analogy between
these two kind of experiments I will
show you the figures fig.2 figures which
have been which are taken from two
papers which have been published back to
back in 1996 in our group in Paris we
detected the signature of an atom or CA
ting an atom coupled to a nauseating
electromagnetic field in a trap and at
the same time in border dead groups was
observed in the same signature from an
ion associating in his trap technically
these associations are called Rabi
oscillations but you don't have to know
anything about them to recognize that
there is a strong similarity between
these two kind of signals it is at that
time in 1996 that Dave and I and our
wives Croydon and Sedna became very good
friends and it turned out that they came
Levin said that came to Europe for a
conference and credit and I took this
opportunity to distract Dave from his
research not really because we wanted to
slow him down in our competition but
because I think we wanted to open them
to the pleasures of European and most
specifically
the French vacation vacation concept
which seems to be absent in United
States so you see here a picture which
was taken in the bubble Riga Gardens in
Florence in August 1996 and this is a
testimony of the fact that dave is not
always working so but the story about
taming atoms and photons started merge
before and they will tell you about his
part of the story I will tell you about
mine which started in the 1960s I
performed my PhD thesis with Claude
cohen-tannoudji and I was working at
that time on optical pumping experiments
learning that lasers could be used to
manipulate atoms and also on the dressed
atom formalism it which is a formalism
which use quantized which quantize the
electromagnetic field to understand
better its interaction with matter and I
remember that my tessie's committee one
member of the committee and a Torah
bhagam who has a very abrasive mind
asked me why do you quantize the field
you are working with classical fields
you have zillions of photons you don't
need to do that I don't remember what I
answered to him but in retrospect I
could have told him one day sir
I will be working with a single photon
and then I would need this dress sat on
approach after my thesis I went for a
postdoc with after shadow in 92 93 and
then I learned to work with dye lasers
which were developing there and I did
quantum bits studies quantum bits
involve exciting atoms and looking at
the time evolution of stage
superposition so I started that time to
work on this concept of state
superposition I just want to mention
that these two gentlemen got the Nobel
Prize in Physics in the year 97 81 and I
remember that 15 years ago I was in this
room but on the other side of the stage
and I am very moved to see that the
cloud is here today and that we
exchanged our roles so
it's very nice so
but the story really started sometime
later in the 1970s when I came back from
Stanford and I started to use dye lasers
to excite Rydberg atoms very excited
atomic states and you know this week in
sue in Sweden is full of surprises I
just met a few minutes ago the grandson
of Rydberg who is attending to this
lecture so I am very pleased about that
so Rick Berg develop gave the formula
which explains the physical pop the the
spectrum of these states and we start to
investigate them with our system which
was very simple we had an atomic beam
which was crossed by lasers tunable
lasers and we are exciting Greenberg
atoms and at the same time we were
radiating this item with microwaves
which were confined in an open cavity
made of copper mirrors and so we are
looking at the microwave absorption
which to which these atoms are
exceedingly sensitive so we are very
interested in this very high sensitivity
after the atom electric ability they
went in this zone where there were
ionized between two condenser plates and
there were analyzed at different times
because the field increased in a ramp
and in this way were able to
discriminate the signature of the upper
and the lower state and this is a
technique that we are using to this day
to detect very efficiently right back
state and transition between Redux
States so when we did that we observed
something which at first was very
strange we saw that if the atom was
initially excited and if the cavity was
tuned on resonance we did not need to
apply any microwave the system was
undergoing a fast transition from the
upper to the lower state spontaneously
and we recognized that who had built a
maser a transient microwave maser
but what was surprising that the
threshold of this Mesa was exceedingly
low we had only a few thousand atoms in
the sample as opposed to ordinary laser
laser system which require
billions of atoms so at the end of the
paper that we wrote at that time we made
a comment saying that by increasing the
Q factor of the cavity
we could go to very small absolute atop
numbers and in fact it was a start of
our hand towards single particle physics
and this field which studies the
interaction of atoms which field within
cavities is now known as cavity quantum
electrodynamics so we kept increasing
the Q factor of our cavity and one way
to do it was to go to superconducting
mirrors so we replaced our copper
mirrors by super conductive niobium
mirror at very low temperature and then
we were indeed able to increase the q of
the cavity and to decrease the threshold
up to the point where we got single
clicks in our detectors and we observe
the fast transfer of a single atom from
the upper to the lower level and which
is the transient regime of a laser and
it's an effect which was predicted by Ed
Purcell in 1935 but we still were not
satisfied because the cue of our cavity
was not big enough for the field to be
able to stay in the cavity long enough
to be reabsorbed by the atoms and what
we wanted to realize is this regime of
quantum mechanical association between a
two-level atom and a single field mode
which is called now the strong coupling
regime of cavity 3G so we went on the
hand to get the strong coupling regime
which became our Holy Grail and we try
to improve the cavity factor so it was a
very exciting time in our lab and I
found a few pictures at this time this
is me with my first two graduate
students Michele goes and caught fat
back to the camera in our office and
here you see Philippe guha who is a
specialist of solid-state physicists who
was working in next index lab and with a
wizard in microwave technology and he
developed all the microwave sources and
microwave analyzers that we use up to
this day so his collaboration has been
essential to the success of our work on
this last picture you see facing me
here you have a cloth fab one can use
knee and facing me jean-michel mo in a
scene in 1980 and I'm glad that we
stayed together and worked in the same
on the same project since then so we
were at a loss to increase the cue of
our cavity at that time niobium was fine
as a superconductor but it's a very poor
material to be machined and so the
surface of our murals were not smooth
enough and the photons were scattered
out and so we were trying to do
something better when we heard from
Munich that Herbert Valtor has succeeded
to reach our Holy Grail getting into the
strong coupling of regime of cavity QED
and so he achieved that before us and it
was at the same time we were very
admirable his work but we were a little
bit worried that we were behind in fact
he had a very bright idea we see
studentdetail method he replaced the
close the open cavity by a cross
cylinder and then the quality of the
inner surface does not matter anymore
and he could increase the photon
lifetime in his cavities by two to three
orders of magnitude and what they built
is the micro laser device where atoms go
through the cavity one by one and they
feel built that builds up in a cavity in
a steady state this micro measure
physics has been very successful in the
1980s and 1990s and detail measurable
became a postdoc of mine when during the
few years I was working part time at
Yale University and then we came back
and became a professor in Bonn and he's
doing now very beautiful experiments on
cold atoms and quantum information and
we have been keeping exchanging students
and postdocs over the years and it has
been a very fruitful collaboration but
so we witness these developments and we
wondered whether we should go to cross
cavities but we still decided it was
better to stick to upward cavities
because this first cavity had a problem
the photon lifetime is very long but you
see that the atoms have to get very
close to the surface of the metal
because they have
to go through very small holes and the
atomic super positions are very
sensitive to stress electric fields
close to the holes so in this experiment
it's very difficult to control the
atomic state and hence the field inside
so we decided we really had to go on
with our open cavities and it took us
about 20 years to develop the technology
which enabled us to get open cavity with
the same kind of queue as these ones say
and this and this led us to the
experiments which bring me here today
but to describe these experiments I
think I will switch from the historical
description to something which will be
more deductive and and phasing the
physics rather than history but I have
to start with the first point usually
when you talk about detecting light you
use the photoelectric effect and the
photoelectric effect which was described
first by Einstein 9:05 destroys the
photons what you have when photons
impinge on a sensitive detector your
retina or a photosensitive cathode you
get clicks which shows that the photon
had been there but you click destroy the
photons so you had a photon and after
the click you have zero photons button
is gone so this is not so much different
from the brute force experiments I
described to you before in fact what you
are observing with your eyes or with any
kind of detector has a day breeze of
collisions of the photon with the
photosensitive surface and this is not
what you want if you want to detect
photons in vivo what you want instead is
the situation where one click leave you
the photon inside your system and so
that you would be able to repeat the
experiments again and again and this is
called a quantum non demolition
measurement and it was pioneered the
theory of this kind of experiment was
pioneered by vladimir against key back
in the 1970s but to achieve that you
need two ingredients you need first a
non demolition detector which works
without absorbing the photon but which
is sensitive at a single photon level
and you also need a very good box to
keep the photons long enough and so we
are back to the photog box that i
discussed in the thought experiment of
Einstein and Bob and the photon box we
came up upon is shown here in fact what
we did during these 20 years was to
improve the surface of our mirrors and
the cue of the cavity increased
progressively it went into 100 micro
second domain in the 1990s which roaders
to do some experiments and then in the
hundreds of milliseconds in the night in
the years 2000 and the final idea was to
use mirrors circle mirrors made out of
copper because copper can be machined
very precisely and on this copper
surface we sputtered a little bit of
niobium so we took advantage of the
mechanical quality of copper and the
electrical quality of niobium and then
we were able to get mirrors on which
light can bounce more than a billion
time making a folded drone it was a
photon of 40 thousand kilometer and
giving a lifetime of 130 milliseconds to
the photon which allows many atoms to
cross the cavity one by one to extract
information from the cavity field and to
perform experiment in which we control
the photons in vivo inside the cavity
but of course for that we need special
atoms and the second point is what kind
of atom we are using we use Rydberg
atoms but and here's a picture of red
bag but we use special Rydberg atoms
called circular ones a circular ring bag
atom is an atom in which by a succession
of laser and radio frequency excitation
you promote one electron to a very large
circular orbit which is a thousand times
bigger than the orbit of the ground
state the techniques with technologies
that we used for doing this kind of
experiment was following the edges of
dan kleppner
we developed it in 1983 and I want here
to acknowledge dance
importance for this physics not only
because of his impact on a red baguette
on physics but also because he was very
important at the beginning of cavity QED
and for instance he performed
experiments on the inhibition of the
NASA mission between murals and I think
that at the beginning of cavity QED the
microwave domain both dan kleppner and
herbert vanta who sadly died in 2006
have been already pioneers and I think
they should be acknowledged it was in
this context if you want to understand
how this atom behaves you have to
remember that electrons are also waves
and so what you have is a de Broglie
wave going around the circle and the
principal quantum number of this excited
state is just the integral number of
waves which can be put inside the
circular orbit and each of this
eigenstate energy eigenstate has a
circular wave going around which is
completely delocalized
you have the same density all around
which means that the system has no
electric dipole but if you want to
copper to light you need an electric
dipole and the way to get an electric
dipole is to go into state super
positions if a purse of microwave
realize a superposition of two adjacent
states with principal quantum number 51
and 50 you prepare a superposition of
these two states which if you wish you
could call a Schrodinger kitten it's
like struggling gasket which is
suspended between life and death States
Eng but of course a very small cat
because it's just a single particle so
we can prepare this kind of systems and
when you do that the two waves which are
50 and 51 nodes interfere constructively
at one end of the orbit and
destructively at the other end and now
you get a big dipole rotating at 51
triggers this dipole is like the hand of
a clock and in fact what we are built
here either what we are doing here is
the building of a read-back clock which
is ticking at 51 gigahertz and we will
use this clock to measure light
non-destructively
the important part is that the atom will
be slightly detuned from the cavity so
that the photons will not be up
emitted in the cavity but still there
will be an effect and this brings me
back to the contribution of Claude who
discovered in 1961 that non-resident
light modifies that with the energy
level these are the light shift set
which have had a tremendous importance
in all kind of atomic physics and
quantum optics experiment during the
last 30 years in our field what happens
that when the atom cross the cavity the
energy levels are slightly shifted
upward and downward which means that the
phase accumulation of the atom going
between the mirrors is different
depending upon the intensity of the
field and the effect is so sensitive
that you can get a phase shift per
photon find out as loud as pie 180
degrees this means that whether you have
zero or one photon in the cavity the
dipole will point in one direction or in
the opposite direction and if you are
able to measure the phase of this dipole
you will count photons without
destroying them of course if you want to
measure a phase you need an
interferometer so we built around our
cavity and interferometer which is made
of two auxiliary microwave zones r1 and
r2 in which we apply Parris's of
microwave before the atom enters the
cavity and after the autumn leaves the
committee the first first prepares the
state superposition which starts ticking
and the second purse is a flash of
microwave which allows us to analyze the
face of the superposition this
succession of time-resolved purses is
known as a ramsey interferometer it was
introduced by ramsey 1949 and it became
the standard device of atomic clocks I
know that Ramsey was day one and speech
the advisor so you see that our story is
entangled in many ways so we use this
exist set up and with this set up we
were able to detect single photons in
fact if you have a phase shift of Pi per
photon where the second Ramsey Saunders
is to map the to dipole States which are
opposite in two states E and G which are
finally detected in the detector and you
get so what we have built is an atomic
clock which is delayed by the photons
which are trapped inside the clock I am
a little bit ashamed to talk you about
an atomic clock which has an accuracy of
terminal seven because they will talk
about clocks which have an accuracy of
10 minutes 17 but his clocks are I must
say insensitive to light which is not
interesting us we want to have a clock
which is very sensitive to light and so
we use red bag atoms so you see here is
a kind of signal a blue bar means R atom
in level G a red band item in Level II
and you see in real time the kind of
observation we get and when we got for
the first time this signal were really
very excited you see here that you have
a jump yeah it means that you have zero
photon in the cavity one photon and then
back zero photon and this photon is just
a blackbody photon the cavity is very
cold and from time to time due to
Planck's law one photon pops in the
cavity and goes out and we measure this
and we see exactly the time when the
quantum jumps sudden change of the right
field occurs here these quantum jumps by
the way were predicted by quantum theory
long ago but in spite of that people
like Sheldon I didn't believe in them
the quotation I gave you in the
beginning comes from an article which
title is very speaking for him itself he
says as a quantum jumps so these are
quantum jumps observed with light and
Dave will show you in his talk quantum
jumps occurring in single ions which had
been observed 20 years before we did our
experiment all night but this was the
first time the quantum jumps were
observed on night you see also that
hundreds of atoms see the same pattern
the atoms cross the cavity one by one
and they all agree that there is a
button inside so it's very
non-destructive we could extend also
this experiment to measure high effort
numbers then of course a single atom is
not enough you have to send a sequence
of atoms and each atoms extract a little
bit of information at the start of the
experiment we
inject a small microwave classical
microwave filling the cavity we don't
know how many photons are in so the
histogram is flat you the probability of
a being from zero to seven photons is
uniform and as you will see the computer
which is hooked to the experiment will
show that this probability as your coin
formation changes in time and after a
few times of atoms across the cavity one
photon number suddenly emerges and
survives here five buttons and we were
very excited when we saw this for the
first time because this is under your
eyes the collapse of the wavefunction
you start with a system which is in a
superposition of proton number States
and in the end by the way of acquiring
information the system collapses into a
given number this experiments of course
and phases the particle aspect of light
as I told you before so maybe first I
should add something we could follow on
a longer time scale what happens to the
field once it has been prepared in a fog
state and you see here the quantum jumps
of a field initially containing four or
seven photons and very recently we are
able to do something more than that not
only to observe the field but to react
back on the field and to preserve the
field into a given photon number you see
here that we can stabilize the field
either in state containing four photon
or seven photon this is called Quantum
feedback because it is an extension to
the quanta quantum systems of the
classical feedback method which are used
to stabilize the classical quantity you
just core you observe and correct for
changes here we correct for changes for
instance by injecting one proton or sub
starting at one proton on demand but as
I just said we want now to explore the
wave nature of this photon the cavity
and this duality between wave and
particles is of course one of the
deepest aspect of quantum theory and
Bohr and the size the point that which
aspect is observed depends upon the kind
of experiment you are doing and this is
a metaphor here you
you can read this ambigram either as
light is a wave as light is a particle
depending upon your state of mind so I
want now and this time began is is has
been drawn by Douglas Hofstadter what I
want you now to get it is a frame of
nine stating that light is a wave and
this will lead us to the discussion of
Schrodinger's cat I remind you the story
and you know it you have a big animal
bigger object an animal in a box an atom
in the linear superposition of two
states one states leaves the animal
alive and the other state triggers a
contraption which kills the animal and
if you are half way between the excitons
lower state you get an entangled
superposition with cat which is half
dead and have a life in a quantum
superposition in our version of the
experiment we still have one atom but we
replace this cat not because we don't
want to make a cruel experiment but
because we cannot do it on a large
system we replace it by system made of a
few photons and we do that to understand
that I have to give you just one piece
of theory here a classical field a field
which has a well-defined phase and
amplitude which is produced by a
classical source is classically a point
in phase space it's a complex number
which has an amplitude and a direction
according to quantum laws it cannot be a
point you have quantum uncertainty in
fact it's a fuzzy ball here which has a
Gaussian distribution this Gaussian
distribution contains all the
information you want to have about the
field technically it's called the digna
function it's a 2d real function which
describes the state of the field so you
can prepare the states very easily and
then by sending red bag atoms of the
cavity you can manipulate this Vigna
function into other shapes and one thing
we did 20 years ago with our colleagues
with the V Division is in degree from
Brazil was to find out that the same set
up which was used to measure
non-destructively the photons could be
you
with a single atom to prepare a
Schrodinger cat state a superposition of
to feed the four posit phase one will be
the lifeguard the other one's a dead cat
and in between fringes which describe
the superposition this kind of situation
is quite different from a statistical
mixture the fact that you have a live or
a dead cat you don't know which but
without this superposition this is a
classical state and this is a quantum
state so we described in this paper how
to build these quantum states and in
fact we are able to do it in a very
simple way to again our Rams
interferometer we start by preparing a
field in the cavity then we send the
single atom prepare it in a
superposition of state this atom crosses
the cavity and it imparts to the field a
phase shift which takes opposite signs
depending upon whether the atom is in
the upper and the lower state so you get
at this point an entangled State
this entangled state is a typical single
cut situation and you can also look at
it as a typical measurement situation
this state is a kind of meter which
points in different direction
you
happens in all measurements so you get
an entanglement in the measurement and
then the atom crosses the second zone
and the second zone makes the states
again which maintains the Katz ambiguity
and in the end when you detect the atom
in one state or the other you project
the field into a cat so I don't have
time to enter into the details but we
can reconstruct the digna function of
this cat by sending strip ii items
across the cavity by a modified version
of the QED measurement and repeating the
measurement many many times of many many
copies we can reconstruct the Shonan be
a cat and this is an experimental cat
you see the two bands which Ravel and
alive and dead animal and also the
quantum interference is in between this
cat has about 2.5 photon on average and
since then we have made slightly larger
cut but you see we are still very far
from having a macroscopic system
furthermore these superpositions are
very fragile the coupling to the
environment washes out these features
and transform the cat very quickly into
a mundane
state mixture the people the person who
described the theory and the role of the
environment in the transformation of the
cat from a superposition into a mixture
is vacek's Yorick from Los Alamos and we
were inspired by his theoretical work to
do our experiments you see here that you
can indeed see how the Vigna function
evolves by taking snapshots of this
vignette functions at increasing times
and you see how the cat evaporates how
the quantum nature of the cat evaporates
with time this experiment can be seen as
an exploration of the boundary between
the quantum world where quantum state to
the position exist in the classical
world an earlier version of the
experiment done 15 years ago with the
cavity which was not as good had also
had already revealed that the coherence
of the cat decades and it decays faster
when the distance between the two state
of the superposition is increased I
think at this point I want to conclude
by making some connections with more
recent
developments here I'm talking about Red
Dog atoms and microwaves and
superconducting cavities but you have
had also very beautiful experiment which
start in 1980s in the optical domain the
cavities and Max Laura dielectric
mirrors and called atoms cross the
cavity in the interaction of these cold
atoms with his optical cavities or
microchips has led to very interesting
experimental pioneers being Kimber in
Caltech and gal trampy in Munich in
other developments you can replace the
cavities by the vanishing field in a
whispering gallery mode of his
microsphere
micro toroid and again beautiful
experiment have been done in solid state
physics you can embed quantum dots
between Bragg layers and again gate
cavity QED going on and last but not
least there have been a very important
development lately called circuit QED in
which artificial atoms which are small
circuits with Joran junctions coupled to
coplanar lines or three different boxes
in the radio frequency domain and this
these systems which are now studied in
many laboratories in the world are very
similar to our microwave cavity
experiments and in fact a lot of
beautiful experiments preparing Fox
stage funding like that states are doing
quantum informations are now being
developed with the system in secret QED
I just give you an example this is our
cat in cavity QED and this is a similar
cat obtained at Yale University this
year you see that you see you have
exactly the same kind of physics the
difference is that in secret QED things
go much faster so you can accumulate
data faster and also you can be
integrated better the two-level systems
together because you can use little
graphic techniques which are very
convenient and so this is a very maybe
very useful device for quantum
information but I leave the discussion
about quantum information to Dave and I
want now to make a few personal remark
see finally using two or three minutes
for that I want first to emphasize that
all this has been a collective adventure
I have been working as I already said
for a very long time with jean-michel MO
and for more than 20 years with Nichelle
Boyle and nothing would have been
possible without this long-term
collaboration we directed the group
together we had this long discussion
decided in which direction we wanted to
go we made sure Michelle Michelle made
many seminal contributions to the
understanding of the system and it's
quite clear that it would not have
worked without them so I think as I
deserve to share the whole of the prize
with me and this purple surprise
I also want to say that of course we are
not alone we had we have counted more
than a hundred people during the last 30
years students postdocs and visitors and
this is the last generation the people
who gathered on October 10th of this
year and I want to mention specially ego
duchenko and Sebastian gray two young
researchers who played a very important
role in the last series of experiments
that I described to you I also want to
say that all this came also through
collaboration with people from outside
and I'm very glad here to see that you
have a lot of people with whom we have
been working in the world who around
were in this room I think it's a
privilege of a profession of our it's
not the profession of our passion to be
able to meet people everywhere in the
world we share the same ideals the same
the same wish to find by just mere
curiosity new things about nature and
this really has nourished us I want also
to finish by talking about the place
where this research has been doing and I
want to say that the spirit of freedom
which I enjoyed and which our group
enjoyed comes back to the legacy of
Alfred cast layer and Rumble sail who
created the lab in the 1950s and you see
this picture was taken exactly in the
same room as a previous one but 46 years
earlier on the day that Alfred Castle
Nobel Prize was announced as you can see
Claude and I looked different from
outside but I think he agrees that
inside I don't see the difference in our
minds now to conclude with even more
personal remarks of course I have a
thought for my parents and for all the
people who are no longer here and
have really enjoyed this this time but I
want also to add that more than
everything else nothing would have been
possible without Claudine with whom I
have shared all these years
I must say that I don't see if I should
see her or you her mind and her
intelligence and her sense of humor have
been really fueling me during all these
years and this goes much beyond science
and physics and we have known each other
much before I knew anything about
photons in fact we met when we are very
young and then there was this kind of I
don't know how you call it an
interruption of many years and the
circumstances of life made that we
encountered again at the time I was I
was like this and if you think that I am
young on this picture what you would you
save the next one this picture was taken
in Casablanca in the winter of 1990 and
you see at that time clothing the only
difference that croydon was as big as I
am but I think she has not changed
besides that and you see also that for
some very strange reason it the winter
in Casablanca is very mild but for
strange reasons my parents had dressed
me already with the overcoat which is
almost ready for the stoker winter thank
you very much
thank you very beautiful and touching
talk and now we continue the program and
the next speaker will be David Wineland
David Wineland was born in 1944 in
Midway Waikiki in the United States he
got his PhD 1970 from Harvard University
Cambridge his group leader and NIST
fellow at the National Institute of
Standards and Technology in the lecture
English University of Colorado Boulder
USA with the stage is yours
so well first of all I of course like to
thank the Nobel Committee for inviting
me here and I have to say I think both
Serge and I agree that it's a wonderful
honor but wouldn't have happened without
many great colleagues and also the work
of people and many other labs so you
will hail this a little bit the same
story again this is my version of kind
of the Schrodinger cat so you know what
I always had one had great admiration
for someone like Schrodinger who cursos
want any inventors of quantum mechanics
but at the same time he was willing to
think ahead and and he was dissatisfied
with the theory in there and the and the
reason basically is that if you take
quantum mechanics alone where you were
both surgeon aia and others are used to
thinking about very small systems single
atoms single photons but the the theory
should apply for the very large systems
and early on Schrodinger realized that
and he he to to explain his the problem
he had he posed this example where a cat
and a radioactive particle were in a in
a sealed box so that there was a closed
system we say and in any case the his
example in this his example the if the
particle decayed it would trigger a
mechanism that would release poison and
kill the cat well in fact of course we
can't write down the equations of motion
for the system but it'd be too difficult
but in principle we can and basically
all quantum mechanics tells us is that
after a time equal to the so called
half-life of the particle all we can say
is that
from quantum mechanics is that the the
the the state of the system is where the
the particle has not decayed and the
Canada's alive and not or but and the
particle has decayed and the cat is dead
and we represent this mathematically
within these symbols here but but the
but the key thing is that all we can say
is that the cat is neither dead nor
alive it's both so that was of course
what bothering Schrodinger now one thing
I this idea of superposition which the
Schrodinger can is a good example of I
think I like this example a Kris Munroe
found this book when he was in our group
and anyway I think it's a it's a really
nice example you can think of it if you
think about this box up here and if you
of course play with your eyes you can
either see this surface here being the
foreground or this or the the surface on
the upper right be in the foreground
then so you tend to see either this
surface and the foreground of that
surface in the foreground and and what's
I think it's a useful analogy because
this in this picture here it basically
has both properties so and and this is
what we call superposition in quantum
mechanics there's something ambiguity
about which state the boxes in and it
actually possesses both properties
simultaneously the the other thing is
that when we when we talk about doing
measurements on quantum systems we
talked it's called collapse or
measurement projection and this example
also shows that I think in a nice way
because when you look at this box here
and you know for example at an instant
you might see this surface being the in
the foreground like this picture here
that's very much like measurement in
quantum mechanics even though the in the
in the superposition state the Box has
both properties when we measure
one feature will will come out and
that's very much like measurements in
quantum mechanics and then we talk about
entanglement in our system then so if
you'll at least opened a suggestion here
the idea is if you have two boxes like
this at least for me I tend to see if I
see this this surface being the
foreground like down here I tend to see
the other surface also be in the
foreground and so when we measure these
entangled system there's a there's a
correlation so in this example here when
if we measure this surface to be in the
in the foreground then we tend to see
this surface also be in the in the
foreground and so this this analogy it
kind of explains this idea of this
entangled superposition and just coming
back briefly to two Schrodinger's cat if
we to show the entanglement we call this
an entangled state where the the we have
this correlation of the particle not
decayed and the cat alive and the
particle decayed and they can't bed and
those so if we see the particle when we
do the measurement and undecayed then
the cat is alive and so on so well
anyways of course as I say shorting was
bothered by this and this consequence of
the theory and and he really struggled
it was this you know throughout his
career and so at one point he may be
maybe out of frustration he said well
look at we you know we tent we cook up
these situations with simple systems
like atoms and but maybe that's maybe
that leads us down the wrong path and
the way he said this is it so one way
out of that according to him was that
you know we we can cook up these
so-called thought experiments but that's
going to lead to trouble and a and and
and in fact we can never deal with
single atoms or molecules and so and at
least are these ridiculous consequences
like Schrodinger's cat well in fact we
now know that
that we can enter this world and but we
so far we can only do it on very small
systems but nevertheless I'll try to to
show you that they have all the features
of Schrodinger's cat and to get to this
point what we need is we first of all we
need precise control of these systems
and lasers and computers and so on that
helped us to do that we also need to
isolate our small simple systems from
the environment so that these
superpositions aren't aren't disturbed
and so the target is here - at least to
start to see some of these of X's that
precise control and being able to
control small numbers of particles so
I'm gonna I'm gonna take a sort of a
personal view through this I think
basically what's nice for me and the way
the citation read for the award is it
basically everything in my career led up
to the to the kind of things we're doing
now so it'll be a little bit of a
personal story but of course again
that's many other people involve this in
this kind of work over the years so this
is a picture of Norman Ramsey's group I
was a graduate student and Ramsey's
group at the time he and dan kleppner
developed the hydrogen maser and many of
you know that Norman here was later part
of the citation for his Nobel Prize was
this development of the hydrogen maser
so that's that's me they're trying to
get close to the boss and so so my
thesis was to to make a deuterium
measure to measure its hyperfine
frequency and and one thing I always
muse over is the fact that I'm probably
the only person in the universe that has
that number memorized
so anyway that was a result of my thesis
but anyway this was good training in the
sense that to get these high Precision's
in these frequency measurements we have
to have very good control over the the
systems environment in this case the
hydrogen maser also this they won't go
much into this but when that when the
atoms are radiating they're in a
superposition state between the ground
and excited state and these these these
atoms in the maser would live on the
order of these super positions of the
atoms in the in this in this Hydra and
this deuterium maser would last about a
second this was not at the single
particle level this was on an ensemble
of atoms that were inside that they in
the microwave County so after after
getting my degree I went on to work with
on stay melt and that although he was
interested also in in atoms and in this
case charged atoms the focus of his work
then was to to deal do his experiments
on on electrons and during the time I
was there we developed techniques to
look at single electrons so a good
picture to have a manically show a an
electrode structure here that holds the
electrons and you can think about them
oscillating back and forth and a good
analogy for that system is you can think
about a marble in a bowl that the marble
rolls back and forth another analogy
which some of you may get is it that if
we we can think about this system this
charged electron and inside of this
electrode structure it it's it's
mimicked by a so-called tuned circuit an
inductor and a capacitor in series and
if we stick this then this equivalent
circuit into a simple electronic system
where we if we drive the the the tuned
circuit on resonance will we'll get a
current through a resistor which we can
read out and the reason that was that
was interesting to help
to try to find at least isolate single
electrons in this experiment is that we
could basically drive the the
oscillations in this equivalent circuit
or this amplitude of the marble in the
bowl and in this experiment here what we
did is we we started out with seven
electrons in our in our atomic bowl and
we we drove it just at an amplitude
where occasionally one of the electrons
would fly out of the bowl go over the
edge and we'd see this this step process
and time and and and so we'd see the
individual electrons leave and we got
down to this last step here that was the
identified a a single electron and then
we could go on and do measurements on
this single electron in a very briefly
then of course hunts demo tennis and his
later colleagues went on to do an
accurate measurement of the magnetic
moment of a single electron and and in
fact this led to game day melts Nobel
price that is this precise measurement
of the magnetic moment of the electron
so at the same time we were we were also
thinking about ideas about how atomic
ions might be used for quacks coming
back to my graduate school work and and
there was one of the things we would
would like to do is to reduce the
temperature of the of the atoms in our
case the ions and so we had some ideas
about laser cooling and at the same time
also
Ted hench and our cello had had some
similar ideas they didn't look so
similar in these in these brief
write-ups but they're in fact very
closely related
so anyway at that after after my postdoc
work with hunt stay multi went to
National Bureau of Standards which is
now called NIST the National Institute
of Standards and Technology so my first
task was to help get the the atomic beam
machine the cesium beam frequency
standard going and fortunately at that
time my boss the fellow that hired me
Helmut Hovig at that time mister NBS was
pretty much of a service organization at
least the part that did the frequency
standards and so helmet was very
instrumental he kind of beat on the
administration to give us some money to
start experiments that first to do the
laser cooling and then from then on
apply that today to atomic clocks and so
that was really the start of this
business and in my career at NBS and
anyway so we did some experiments and at
the same time
Peter Toshack's groups was doing some
experiments and actually hunts demos and
joined them on this and what's kind of
interesting you notice of the dates of
publication are very close together we
were a little early earlier than the our
paper was published a little earlier
than that of Peter Toshack's group but
to be fair you see that they actually
submitted their paper a day a day early
so I guess you'd have to say there they
were the first and so one thing is
interesting about this is I think I knew
because that they were working on this
because I knew Hans DeMuth had gone to
spend a sabbatical and in that group I
don't think they knew we were working on
so it was really a kind of an amazing
coincidence that that this work was
submitted within a day
of each other anyway are in this in the
experiment that in Peter Tosh X group
the the evidence for for cooling was
that they were able to hold the ions
into the trap for much longer time based
on the techniques I had learned I told
you about the induced currents that we
could measure of electrons in this case
we just looked at the thermal currents
of the of the ions in the trap and we
could if we turn the laser on we could
see the temperature go go down which was
just a measure of these and measured by
these induced currents and we could see
the cooling effect in that way so this
was this was the R group in 79 not not
very long after these first laser
cooling measurements and that the the
embarrassing part I think at least for
me is I can see III aged a little bit I
I must submit a both wane Titano who's
here and Jim Burke rest haven't they
don't look much different but I think
Bob drawing area over here who's who's
also here we we suffered from the
ravages of time I would say so anyway
that the you know moving on one of the
one of the goals was certainly at NBS
NIST was to try to apply these these
cooled ions for frequency standards the
reason that's important is that is that
we want to reduce what are called
Doppler shifts and what I'm one of the
more interesting Doppler shifts is the
so called time dilation shift this comes
from nine Stein's here relativity if the
ions are are moving inside this this
trap we call it then the time runs
slower for them this is the basis of
Einstein's twins paradox and so the the
laser cooling would be very important
for that to reduce this this this type
this rate of time
shift and so that was the importance
there but nevertheless we also wanted to
think about getting the number of atoms
we're reusing the clock to very small
numbers and the reason for that is just
that we can control the environment a
much better first for single atoms or
ions than we can for a large ensemble so
in this in this with this that actually
the the first experiments isolating
single ions where these experiments also
again in Peter Toshack's group and they
actually miss made some pictures of
single barium I'm in this case our work
was a little bit later we also went back
to the same idea that I showed you with
electrons in this case we kicked
magnesium ions at one at a time by using
a chemical charge exchange process but
we can we could identify the the ions at
the at the single ion level you see here
the same the last step in this picture
indicated and when we had a single ion
so anyway we we carried on have carried
on with these experiments after that and
the idea again and this is in the
context of clocks one of our favorite
choices was mercury it had two
transitions one in the microwave region
and also one in the optical region that
might potentially be used for clocks so
schematically what we had is a this
electrode structure this kind of
doughnut shaped things and some some
other things down here we call in caps
anyway that the the idea was that if
what I show here is an energy diagram
and we if we tune a laser beam such of
this radiation connects this lower level
to this excited level then the atoms can
scatter photons and if we tuned the
laser cooling process relies on tuning
this laser slightly below the resonance
frequency of this transition the thing
that made this hard was that this this
wavelength was in the in the in the
ultraviolet in
this is where Jim burkas was key to it
to these to this work because he was the
he's the laser expert and continues to
be the laser expert in our group so the
idea of a clock the way we could make a
clock on this there's another transition
in mercury and this one is the feature
that it's it has a much much narrower
range of frequencies over which it
absorbs and so we can get higher
precision on the frequency of the laser
when we make this this transition one
interesting thing is that we can use
this this transition that we use for the
cooling to detect when the when the when
this transition is made because when if
the ion is promoted from this ground
level up here to this particular excited
level then the scattering on this on
this laser cooling transition will go
will will be diminished and we can tell
then when we make the transition with
the laser tuned to the so-called clock
transition at this time there was there
was a bit of controversy among the among
the theorists about whether if we did
this experiment that is if we if we
tuned this laser and and hit this
resonance transition would this
scattered light just diminish sort of
smoothly or with the atom sort of jump
from one state to the other that is what
would it be either here or here and in
fact in fact they the atom does jump
twin as indicated by jumps in this
scattering so if we promote the atom up
here and then the light just completely
shuts off rather than being just
diminished and and these again they the
same same people this was now a Danish
group and Peter Toshack's group in our
group that did some experiments on this
about the same time so so I have to
we have much fancier versions of these
things now but this will give you an
idea of like they are a little movie
made in 86 showing these jumps so this
shows this same kind of electrode
structure this is the doughnut here and
the pictures get poorer and quality here
the first net that was the trap just
mounted on a penny this is now looking
through a window of a vacuum system but
you can still make out the the ring the
doughnut shaped structure and the
so-called BIM camp and then this this
picture is taken with an ultraviolet
camera and its quality is pretty poor
you still see the outline of the of the
of the doughnut the inner inner part of
the doughnut here and as the movie goes
on you can start to see the scattered
light from in this case this this single
mercury ion and what we're doing here is
we're tuning the cooling laser closer
into residence of the atom will scatter
more and more photons but but while it's
changing state you can start to clearly
see the the atom blinking on and off and
when it's when it's not scattering that
means it's in this upper right hand
level and you can see clearly see these
so-called quantum jumps so from this
work we we we wanted to go farther this
was this was a way to detect the quantum
levels of course of the of the that were
affected by the lasers but we also
wanted to control much finer level the
the the levels of motion in the in the
of the ion and the trap so if I if you
expand the this this black line here
basically the these the classical
picture again of the the ion and the
trap is this marble and the bowl but in
the quantum picture what we need to
think about are are the energy levels
the ground energy level and the atom is
closest to rest that we can get it going
on up with excited so-called excited
States and of the of the quantized
emotional now these the gap between
these these the first the ground and
first excited state of the motion is
about eight orders a magnitude
100 million times smaller than the gap
for this for the energy of the photons
that are driving the laser transition so
we had of course I'd have much better
control to be able to control down to
the quantum levels of the motion so what
this picture shows is if we if we tuned
this laser such that when we when we
drive the this so-called electronic
transition if we if we tune the
frequency of the laser so that that the
emotional energy does State doesn't
change then we can see a feature here
what this shows is the probability of
seeing fluorescence and of course when
we hit the transition then the scatter
the probability of the of seeing the
scattered light goes down and which is
why these you see these dips here we can
also tune the laser so that when we if
we start in this say this in equal to
level we can we can change the
electronic level and also increase the
motional quantum level by one which is
indicated by that feature there we can
also do the other side and and if we go
drive the electronic transition and also
decrease the emotional state by one way
that's indicated by that picture there
so anyway we could start to see these
kind of quantum features in the motion
and one interesting thing we could we
could use this this so-called these
sideband features the to do a further
kind of cooling in this case first of
all the conditions were such that if
after the atom was excited to this upper
a manifold of states when it decayed the
conditions were such that it would decay
back down without changing its quantum
number so the idea of this further
cooling was that we would we would we
would excite on this this so-called red
sideband the lower frequency transition
so if we if we started here we would
decrease the
the motional quantum number by one then
we would let the atom decay and we would
repeat this process so that if we if
excited them there it would eventually
come down to that level and the
interesting thing of course is that when
we get down to this lower level then
there's no excited energy level motional
energy level for this for the atom to go
to those so the scattering stops and the
way and that was then an indication what
you're seeing on this right-hand picture
that this feature here collapses down
into this this feature here and
similarly this one represents one here
and you can see a big asymmetry now in
the in these features and the fact that
this this will called the red sideband
is disappearing means we're
predominantly in this situation here
where we don't get any absorption and
the atom is then indicates the atoms in
its ground motional state as well well
anyways let me just come back a little
bit to the clocks that we got that with
the with the with the cooling and the
and trapping and laser cooling and
trapping we could we could reduce these
Doppler shifts and taking some other
care to reduce other collision other
perturbations to the system
Jim Bergquist is the main person that
has led this work and this really
started in 1981 and his experiments on
on Mercury were there actually the first
clocks to exceed the performance of the
of the cesium beam frequency standards
and nowadays we all think about optical
clocks rather than microwave clocks in
terms of high performance anyway so
around 1995 these ideas of quantum
information processing more commonly
referred to as quantum computing came
around there were some early ideas by
people like Richard Feynman
there's but and they would they were
just kind of toy ideas I would say and
then what we really set the field off
was that the Peter Shore computer
theorist came up with an algorithm that
said if you could make this quantum
computer you could efficiently factorize
large numbers the reason that's
important is it if we could if we could
accomplish this task on very large
numbers that would have very important
implications for encryption and secret
coding basically anyway not long after
Peter shor made announced described his
algorithm actually art director who was
already a an accomplished person in
quantum communication came and gave us a
lecture to the atomic physicists on this
presenting these ideas of quantum
computation and and fortunately both
Peters Oller who's in the audience and
and his protege at that time Ignacio
serac they they they quickly jumped onto
this idea of quantum computing and they
came up with the first scheme for how
you might build a quantum computer and
it was based on ions so the idea is here
this is if this picture is distant
represent some sort of electrode
structure you can still think of the
marbles in a bowl in some sense in this
case it's kind of a linear Bowl where
the the ions all want to follow the
bottom of the bowl but the Coulomb
repulsion due to their charge holds them
apart anyway their idea was that you in
in this example of five ions it's kind
of like a pseudo molecule you can think
about the normal modes the vibrations of
the molecule and they all have different
frequencies in general so you can think
about the the ground and first excited
state of this of the of one of these
modes of motion of the molecule also as
what we call a quantum bit in other
words a two-state system that were
and that can represent information and
their idea was that they would use the
internal states of of ions that could be
their optical states like I showed with
the clocks or hyperfine States that in
principle doesn't matter anyway their
idea was to be able to make quantum
gates if they could if they could with a
laser beam if we could somehow map this
superposition state on to this emotional
state then we would then we would this
emotional state is interesting because
it's shared with all the eye and say
Allianz share one motional mode and then
that to make a gate in between the two
ions you'd first do this mapping step
and then from on a second selected ion
you'd do a quantum gate between the
motional mode and the internal state of
this ion which has then basically have
made a gate between the the first
selected ion and the second selected I'm
so I won't give you details of exactly
how this works but I give you a kind of
a sense of how logic gates work so if we
have this in this case it might be an
optical transition and and if we isolate
these two lower emotional quantum levels
which also represent a quantum bit then
one way you can kind of get the idea of
how logic gate works is if if we have a
truth table down here and the idea is
that if if this was this bit
representing the motion is is called the
if we refer to that as the control bit
and this is the this is the quanta
so-called target bit then the idea is if
we if we tuned to this transition where
the where we reduce the quantum number
by 1 then the idea is if the control bit
is in the N equal one level we can do
this transition in other words we flip
the the bit of the of the target the
target bit if it's if it's in the ground
state
again there's no place for this to go so
the
the the target bit doesn't flip so we
get this kind of logic table and this
was a little too simple but it gives the
essence of the idea this logic gate
anyway so Chris Monroe who was in the
group at that time we you know we could
we were kind of poised to do this so we
could jump on this idea right away and
we were able to demonstrate a more more
general logic gate that that both
Ignacio and Peter had described the one
thing I want to say is that for both
Peter and Ignacio is that this really
stimulated the the ion trap field and
this is the I buy less my last count the
number of the people working on just
quantum information related experiments
with just with ions and of course
there's many other implication possible
implementations of quantum information
and and so this but anyway both Peter
and Ignacio have gone on to stimulate a
lot of work in other areas as well so
it's it it give myself in the time
everybody let me let me give the little
version of another version of
Schrodinger's cat so you think about
this marble in the bowl what we can do
is that we can first start the the atom
in its grounds internal state we can
then apply radiation to make a so-called
superposition of the of the ground and
excited state then what we can do is
that we using so-called optical dipole
forces we can apply a force to the to
the to the atom but it's a force which
only acts on the on the upper state not
the lower state so we can we can start
to separate the this superposition both
as well as in terms of this what we call
the spin and represented by the arrows
but also the position so we can apply a
beam that that starts to push the up
component and it is oscillating back and
forth and then we can flip this spin
and then we apply the same force again
but we can apply it with a little bit
different phase and we can realise this
situation then where the marble is on
the at some instants of time it's both
on the left side of the bowl and right
side of the bowl correlated with the
direction of the spin and there was the
internal energy say and and we would say
this is like this is very much like
Schrodinger's cat and that we we have a
more classical like property the
separation of the of the marbles and are
the the positions of these states in the
bowl correlated with microscopic
property that is the the internal state
of the atom so this is a picture of the
trap we used and this very much like
what Sarah said that we can't make a
very big cat in this sense in fact that
the the wave packet size of the of the
in this case beryllium ion we could make
the the cat state be such that it was
about eight times the size of the wave
packet which is still very small and in
fact after this paper was written we got
to come there was a comment and letters
to the editor and and we called a
Schrodinger kitten buddy even he this
fellow and her organs said that well
even that's too big to call it a
anything like a Schrodinger cat and so
he thought of showing her for boy and I
think what I what I took from this was I
think this is interesting because if
it's if it I think it does have all the
same features as Schrodinger's cat and
if it's in if it's if it's not big
enough how do you define big and I think
none of us know how to define big that
is where does it where does the hit
where do you where does the classical
behavior overtake this quantum behavior
and I think none of us know the
today so let me just say briefly that
you know this subject goes on in a big
way now there's many people working on
it certainly in our lab dd live trade
let a lot of the early algorithm
demonstrations and continues to do that
one of the things I most physicists are
like physicists are looking forward as
to is the idea that these these simpler
systems forget factoring big numbers for
a minute just even small numbers of
particles may be able to to simulate
other systems of interest and one thing
in several groups are thinking of as two
I talked about these these oscillations
of the marbles in the in the bowl and
you can figure those as oscillating
dipoles those can mimic magnetic spins
and a solid and so this is this a
picture of John Boehner's experiment
where he has an array of of ions in a
hexagonal in a hexagonal structure and
this can simulate some interesting spin
systems in condensed matter and and
certainly that certainly at the moment
the best-performing quantum computer you
might say is that is that a variety of
lots group and innsbruck and they're
able to actually at least on a small
scale make a make a real quantum
computer that so far we can simulate
this quantum computer on a classical
computer but I think we're I think we're
all feeling now we're getting to this
threshold where we're going to get to
systems that we can't simulate on the
normal computer anymore that is the
world war we're really going to be able
to use this quantum computer and of
course there's many many more people
working on this as I indicated I'm not
as since I'm running long let me just
say briefly we've gone on to use some of
these ideas these simple quantum
information ideas in our clocks and I
regret that I won't have time to get
full credit but in our lab till Rosa man
leads the project use
aluminum ions as a clock and I won't go
through all my punchlines here except to
say that now this this clock that till
Rosen band has developed is is the
world's most accurate clock and the
sense of getting rid of these
environmental perturbations and in fact
we can see some interesting
gravitational shifts in there in the
clock and this Oh heckle oh yes here
indulgence and we have a little cheesy
movie here which shows this is one of
the aluminum clocks on this optical
table and James Chao here raising it up
on a jack and when we did this we could
we could we could we could measure the
so-called gravitational redshift
gravitational potential redshift in this
experiment and by raising the the table
about 33 centimeters we would predict
the shift like this and we measured at
least within the air or something like
this and this may lead to a new kind of
of weight to measure to do geodesy and
we're looking towards that so let me I
will stop now sorry about it anyway I do
want to again you know I think want to
thank my local colleagues John Bollinger
Jim burkas and Bob drawing and Wayne
attano and I have been together around
30 to 35 years and we're still working
together and more recently BD Live
Frieda and till Rose envenom joined us
and Chris Murrow was really instrumental
in these experiments that I that I
briefly described and and of course if
you know it's really hard to give proper
credit but we've had over a hundred
students postdocs and visitors over the
year and certainly we we've enjoyed
really really good support from our
bosses and particularly I want to
acknowledge Katherine Gibby who's the
head of the lab she's my boss's boss and
and she's been very supportive of this
kind of work and I think
you know certainly her successes may be
partly measured by me but also Bill
Phillips and Eric Cornell Jan Hall who
also received Nobel prizes she has been
the lab director during that time and
finally of course it's been a nice for
you know have nice friends along the way
and including Claudine and and Sayers
this is my wife's Edna and we've
certainly enjoyed their friendship over
the years and sorry there goes so long
but thank you
you
okay now we have heard the two beautiful
lectures about two laureates and now we
have the superposition of them here on
the stage so if the some urgent question
please ask if not you can meet them in
the intermission is it some question
over there yes this were like doing
experiments with with single particles
yet he of course was the the originator
of the idea of the throat of your cat
were others of the founders of quantum
mechanics equally suspicious of the idea
of a single particle experiments or was
it something unique to Schrodinger and
what was his problem
I don't know about all of them but I
think Einstein was dubious too
he had an awesome metaphor he used the
idea of a bomb which is half exploded
and half not exploded which is the
similar idea but maybe got less
publicity because then the cut is more
lava bombs and bomb but I think I just
and did not like this idea about boy
it's difficult to know because you know
that his statements were very cloudy and
I don't know what he would have said I
am sure he would not have been surprised
by the results of these experiments okay
I think with this we thank the speakers
again and in the intermission you can
discuss with them